so i met this girl we're both crazy in
love but she's a nurse in a native
community in a nordic village in quebec
so she's basically only here in montreal
for half of the year
we had an open relationship and we're
managing it well but we recently decided
to be exclusive
so i was wondering what do you guys
think about open relationships can it
really work long term
thanks that guy hit one note and his
whole fat guy
sounds like he was drowning so that's
sexy though for real i think that guy's
[ __ ] sexy yeah i mean i would he's a
cool now you're jealous well i'm not
jealous i think that you shrugged and
you're like well he's not as sexy as me
but no i think that you're just you're
falling victim to he's got an accent
yeah maybe but i think he kind of looked
like robert pattinson too though he's
sexy bro
he doesn't look anything like robert
patton's that guy's handsome and sexy
period have you been in open
relationships no i have been in open
relationships and it's just very hard to
navigate dude it's not easy and he was
in an open relationship and now he's not
with the girl i think that that's
i think that's progress i think that if
you start with an op with with a
non-open relationship exclusive and then
go open i don't think that that's
progress i think that's whatever the
opposite of yeah right right right was
he saying he's considering about going
back to an open relationship i don't
think so i just think that he was asking
do you think open relationships could
work if i'm with someone that is the
person i want to be with
and so having an open relationship i
don't even like yeah part of me doesn't
really quite get it well
you know
thank god you're not an animal you know
what i mean like an actual animal like
you know penguin not a penguin penguins
are monogamous you know what i [ __ ]
read about penguins all look like each
other you know what i read about
penguins the other day this is real
they [ __ ] dead penguins
because the way
sometimes penguins will die in the
position of the way that they position
themselves when they're asking to be
mated with and then a male penguin will
go up to a dead female penguin and [ __ ]
it
i mean
don't shoot the messenger
[ __ ] a dead penguin
penguin dead but not knowing just
yep dude hey
nature
figure that out yeah well dude the [ __ ]
it's a loophole dude how about how
[ __ ] penguins just dying like this
[Laughter]
that's yeah
just with a [ __ ] log in its mouth
with the fins like this
horny penguins coming by
i wonder what that position really is
though penguin style unfortunate
unfortunately
hello
[Music]